Here's a list of different
classification problems that I
came up with.
It can be found in business
such as when an email comes in
classify it as spam or inbox.
Or, is a customer going to
renew a cell phone contract?
Classification problems can also be
seen in scientific use cases such as,
What land cover type is a pixel
from a satellite image?
Or, does a soy bean have a disease or
not?
Classification problems are also all
around us in real world situations.
Like, what color shirt looks best on me?
Or as well, what type of transportation
will employees use to go to work?
Now looking at this list, you will see
that there are classification problems
throughout business, scientific,
and real-world applications.
But if we look at each of the
classification scenarios more in-depth,
we can group them into two buckets,
binary and non-binary.
Binary variables are those
that have two groups and
non-binary variables have
more than two groups.
For example, in the question,
if a soybean has a disease or not,
there are two options.
Yes, the soybean has a disease, or no,
the soybean does not have a disease so
this is a binary classification problem.
Now in the next exercise,
it is your turn,
to identify the binary classification
problems versus the non-binary problems.